gemütlich auf dem sofa chillen und dabei
zusehen wie die hauptfigur der
lieblingsserie im wald erst verfolgt und
dann getötet wird
da bleibt einem doch das ein oder andere
mal das popcorn im hals stecken
denn bei einer richtig guten verfolgung
sagt mit einem solch bedauerlichen ende
bleibt einem doch gar nichts anderes
übrig als so richtig mitzufiebern dazu
kursiert ein video der american chemical
society netz das zeigt was wir alle
schon längst geahnt haben
der zuschauer oder die zuschauer in
eines horrorfilms fühlt sich tatsächlich
ähnlich wie das opfer im film selbst
welche chemischen prozesse beim sterben
und auch beim reinen zugucken eines
mordfalles vom sofa aus in unserem
gehirn ablaufen jetzt den klicks um
science-fiction herzlich willkommen
stell dir vor jemand sagt ich ein mensch
mit einer axt oder sonst jemand der
nichts anderes will als dich umzubringen
vielleicht ist es sogar noch dunkel und
du kannst kaum etwas sehen im großen
wald in dem du dich verirrt hast du
weißt wohl dass du eigentlich keine
möglichkeit hast deinen mörder zu
entkommen
ein echtes horrorszenario also aber so
oder so ähnlich kennen wir es alle und
zwar aus horror filme oder serien oder
krimis und so weiter und so fort und die
gefühle die wir dabei haben die eine
sehr denen der mordopfer im fernsehen
oder im kino also beziehungsweise
derjenigen die das wirklich erleben
das sagt zumindest das video der
american chemical society
also der amerikanischen fachgesellschaft
für chemie das freie netz zugänglich ist
die überwiegende emotion ist eindeutig
angst pure angst dafür sorgen die große
drohende gefahr und der hohe schaden
also der tod der daraus mit aller
wahrscheinlichkeit resultieren wird
zudem ist wohl auch nicht mit hilfe von
außen zu rechnen dein puls und den
blutdruck steigen seine pupillen
erweitern sich und du stehst unter
hochspannung dadurch kommt es zu einer
aktivierung des nebennieren marx wodurch
adrenalin ausgeschüttet wird dadurch
wird für mit glykogen ein vielfach sogar
abgebaut wird aus dem körper mehr
energie zur verfügung steht laut
american society of chemistry werden
angst und adrenalin auf ähnliche weise
aktiviert also sowohl anzuschauen des
horrorfilms als auch bei einem echten
mordopfer beides ist in einem solch
einem krass moment tatsächlich sehr
wichtig für den menschlichen körper
dieser
wirklich komplizierte chemische prozess
führt dazu dass der organismus alarmiert
ist sich bereit zu machen um zu
reagieren beispielsweise wegzulaufen
raus aus der gefahrenzone
das zentrale nervensystem leitet die
signale an den thalamus weiter denn etwa
sowie eine schaltzentrale funktioniert
von hier aus wird die info an anderen
gehirnteile gesendet der körper macht
sich bereit die alles entscheidende
frage für den folgen
entscheidungsprozess lautet kampf oder
flucht das stresshormon cortisol tut
sein übriges dafür sicher ist aber ein
lautes schreien dieses schreien
motiviert schneller zu laufen das pusht
noch einmal deinen ganzen körper das
schreien im film löst dann wiederum
furchtbaren zuschauer oder der
zuschauerin aus wie genau sich der
direkte moment des sterbens dann anfühlt
das wiederum ist noch weitgehend
unerforscht wie sollte das auch gehen
schließlich ist noch keiner der mir
bekannten toten wieder auferstanden
doch es gibt hier versuche dazu demnach
versiegt die gehirnaktivität während des
sterbeprozess nicht allmählich sondern
steigt noch einmal für kurze zeit
deutlich an
das hat beispielsweise ein
forschungsteam der university of
michigan 2013 berichtet dieses ergebnis
könnte gegebenenfalls auch die berichte
von nahtoderfahrungen stützen
das netzwerk nato der erfahrung schätzt
dass etwa vier millionen menschen in
deutschland schon mal so ein mysteriöses
erlebnis hinter sich gebracht haben
beispielsweise nach einem unfall in den
berichten heißt es dann so etwas wie es
fühlt sich einfach an wie ein perfekter
schlaf aber ohne träume andere berichten
davon dass sie es eher wie ein leben
nach dem tod empfunden haben
beispielsweise von einer licht vision am
ende des tunnels oder als eine art
lebens finden in der medizin wird der
zustand nachdem die atmung langsamer
wird und das herz aufhört zu schlagen
als klinischer tod bezeichnet dann folgt
der biologische tod alle organe und
zellfunktionen sind erloschen und danach
kann auch keiner mehr davon berichten
wie es ist zu sterben
doch die forschung kommt diesem moment
immer näher wie wir gerade gehört haben
wenn ihr kein video zum thema und auch
zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollt
dann wird mir hier ein abo aufsaugen
vergessen nicht den genau auf die glocke
nur dann werdet ihr auch immer über neue
videos informiert hier geht es weiter
mit dafür draufklicken todbringende
kinderlähmung ist zurück in europa ja
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran